bonsoir Monsieur roi parce que il y a
des désavantages de venir des villes où
il y a une richesse qui se concentre on
peut plus les familles peuvent fuyer en
fait c'est quand on voit que Toronto est
vancouverte pour nommer ses exemplaires
même si les salaires sont beaucoup plus
élevés qu'à Montréal il y a pas plus
d'accès à la propriété la classe moyenne
n'arrive pas à se loger dans le
centre-ville de Toronto ou Vancouver
alors c'est pour ça que moi je dis ben
non c'est pas juste une question de
salaire qui augmente moi aussi je veux
que les Québécois et de meilleur
salaires mais il y a pas de corrélation
directe pour avoir de l'abordabilité
pour que la classe moyenne puisse se
loger faut des programmes il faut
pouvoir mettre des règlements à faux
interdire les subdivisions les flics il
faut vraiment aller très loin pour
s'assurer qu'on est capable de garder
une même mise sur le marché qu'est-ce
que vous voulez parce que vous avez
laissé entendre monsieur le goût avait
passé de sensibilité pour ce problème là
j'ai dit il y a besoin d'en faire plus
qu'est-ce que vous voulez à court terme
vous la Ville de Montréal pour augmenter
l'offre
nous ce qu'on demande à la suite du
budget où on a été j'ai été très vocal
sur ma déception face au logement on a
cette par exemple projet de logements
sociaux qui sont bloqués les sommes de
d'argent de Québec ne descendent pas à
Montréal ou on est prêt avec les
organismes années construits les projets
sont bien ficelés ça ne descend pas
alors ça c'est très très concret parce
que disent j'ai pas fini exactement les
vieux
vous avez raison mais les sept dont je
vous parle ce sont des vieux également
donc c'est là où on ne comprend pas et
je ne peux pas je suis obligé de dire
sur la place publique donnez-nous les
moyens nos ambitions et nécessairement
quand on voit les familles on voit les
reportages on voit des gens de toutes
sortes de classes sociales qui peinent à
se loger 25% des Québécois québécoises
payent plus de 30 % de leurs revenus
annuels pour se loger ça ça faisait
moins d'argent dans notre économie aussi
donc c'est pas c'est pas une dépense
l'habitation c'est un investissement
pour un gouvernement les logements
sociaux logements abordables je vous le
dites mais il y a des projets qui ne se
font pas à Montréal comme blue burnout
qui fait 1000 ans qu'on en parle
pourquoi ça se fait pas pourquoi il y a
pas déjà des pelles mécaniques la raison
essentiellement ça cause du coût des
infrastructures du terrain parce que
c'est un terrain avec aucun égout il y a
pas d'eau pas d'électricité pas de
transport pas de bruit rien rien donc on
doit partir en neuf puis lorsqu'on a
décidé de faire parce qu'on le veut ce
terrain-là vous avez raison c'est un
terrain qui appartient à la ville de
Montréal nos ambitions pour du logement
familial abordables et sociaux sont
énormes donc là on a décidé de
travailler avec l'ensemble du milieu et
le gouvernement du Québec ce sont des
biens contents que ce soit autour de la
table pour dire qu'est-ce qui doit
débloquer au niveau des modes de
financement les institutions financières
pour dire qui va payer quoi exactement
parce que c'est plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars je parle même pas
des building juste des infrastructures
il faut réfléchir à l'extérieur de la
boîte donc est-ce que il y a pas un
sommaire organisé au plus vite avec
exactement mais non mais merci de le
dire parce que nous ce qu'on je les
disais quand même sur quelques tribunes
moi ce que je fais c'est que le
gouvernement du Québec conserve que
c'est une priorité pour eux l'habitation
qui nous partage décision mais on est là
pour les nourrir moi j'adorerais
participer à ce genre de rendez-vous où
tout le monde comme à Montréal
et promoteurs vous avez raison parce que
blueba net moi je travaille avec
l'ensemble de l'écosystème autour de la
table la ville il y a l'arrondissement
mais il y a également des promoteurs des
constructeurs le milieu de la
construction donc à Montréal on est
mobilisé et on veut faire partie d'une
conversation nationale menée par le
gouvernement du Québec parce que ça va
être une priorité madame plante il y a
une façon il y a une mauvaise façon de
faire baisser les loyers c'est de
laisser un quartier périclité oui
absolument et là dans le village
c'est si près de Radio-Canada donc on
est nous on peut on marche souvent il y
a plus rien sur les commerçants qui
tiennent à bout de bras le quartier là
vous avez comme abandonné ce quartier là
depuis des années pourquoi mais la
raison non je peux pas je peux pas
accepter votre prémisse monsieur ouais
parce que ben non le village mais en
fait la vie ben la vie si j'avais un
résumé le village et médicament ça a
toujours été un quartier quand même où
il y a toujours eu de la vulnérabilité
les gens viennent là parce qu'il y ait
des services des refuges pour personnes
en situation d'Itinérances des CLSC pour
différentes choses mais depuis la
coviste qu'on a remarqué surtout dans le
village une fracture une augmentation
marquée des personnes quand j'ai vu
vulnérables c'est peut-être toxicomanie
santé mentale itinérance tout se
mélangeait et là nous ce qu'on essaie de
faire la ville c'est de mettre plein de
ressources alors demain on va présenter
notre stratégie sur laquelle on
travaille depuis un an avec l'ensemble
du milieu mais le premier point de cette
stratégie là qu'on dévoile demain c'est
la sécurité puis depuis le mois d'avril
on a augmenté
donc depuis le mois d'avril nous on a
pris ce premier axe là on a augmenté le
nombre de présence policières parce que
il y a beaucoup de criminalité la petite
criminalité les policiers sont là pour
arrêter les réseaux les vendeurs de
drogue par exemple on a augmenté le
nombre de d'intervenants sociaux
municipaux parce qu'on s'entend c'est
pas une responsabilité de la ville mais
on a engagé des gens à même la ville
dans les budgets de la ville pour
accompagner les gens qui sont
vulnérables vers les refuges le nombre
de commerce
qui sont partis ces placardés il y a
plus de restos il y en a quelques-uns
puis on les encourage
c'est on n'a pas vu ça vous avez eu le
temps de voir ça venir depuis plusieurs
années en fait je dois vraiment le
redire le monsieur Roy tout le travail
qui est fait je pense mon message c'est
pas de minimiser c'est pas de ne pas
nommer soit le sentiment d'insécurité
des commerçants ou des citoyens il faut
l'entendre puis on l'entend monsieur
Daguerre l'entend aussi le chef de
police mais définitivement depuis la fin
de la covid tout le monde va vous le
dire que dans ce secteur là il y a une
pression incroyable au niveau des
personnes vulnérables moi ce que je veux
c'est transformer le quartier avec les
citoyens avec les gens c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille sur une stratégie depuis
un an ça va pas se faire en deux en
deux minutes mais la volonté est là
qu'on lâchera pas on ne lance plus de
policiers travailleurs sociaux des
investissements également on peut penser
à l'élo voyageurs ça la Ville de
Montréal on va présenter un plan de
développement bientôt il y a le bâtiment
qui a juste en face du parc Émilie
Gamelin on est en train de réfléchir
avec les partenaires à l'identité du
village on a vu que depuis qu'on a
enlevé les boules de Monsieur Cormier
les boules pauvre tout cet été
pour une période déterminée on a essayé
de le convaincre mais je pense que de
votre faute mais je dis non regarde ça
on regarde ça puis-je on se dit la ville
quand même une responsabilité on a une
responsabilité et on agit mais ce que je
dois absolument mentionner c'est que
responsabilité là et tout de même
partager dans la mesure quand il y a de
la détresse humaine quand il y a trop
détresse humain dans un quartier là
aussi on a besoin de se poser la
question où sont la santé et service
sociaux il doit être centres de jours on
pourrait pas les refuges ben oui moi à
la limite si on veut mettre ce genre de
ressources là mais j'ai besoin d'avoir
la santé les services sociaux qui est
dans cette dans cette logique et là avec
la stratégie ils font partie de la
solution mais il faut aller plus loin
avec eux bon
maintenant on parle de gens vous avez
parlé de sans-abri des gens vulnérables
Barry en Ontario je vous entends de
là-dessus la municipalité dit on va
donner des contraventions et très
coûteuses à des gens qui vont aller
porter de la nourriture ce sera interdit
d'aller aider dans les parcs parce
qu'ils veulent pas que les sans-abris
s'installe dans les parcs la nourriture
que votre réaction
honnêtement parce que je les connais là
c'est municipalité là sur l'échelle
canadienne clairement pour moi c'est un
échec de nos sociétés d'offrir du
logement à ces populations là quand
c'est rendu qu'il y a des gens qui
habitent dans la rue les municipalités
font ce qu'elles peuvent avec les moyens
du bord un peu comme Montréal aussi
quand on crée une brigade d'intervenance
sociale mais au final l'habitation c'est
ça fait partie de la mission d'un état
que soit l'Ontario que ce soit le Québec
c'est la même chose il faut aider les
personnes vulnérables dans la rue on
peut pas les laisser comme ça mais en
même temps c'est d'une tristesse de dire
à des gens on va vous punir parce que
vous voulez aider des plus démunis
mais je veux vraiment c'est scandaleux
mais sans le ramène plus haut ça n'a pas
de bon sens qu'un État comme l’ont a une
promesse comme l'Ontario accepte qu'il y
ait des démissionner sur l'itinérance au
point où les itinérants s'installe puis
il y a des risques d'incendies il peut y
avoir des accidents il peut avoir plein
de choses les municipalités elles elles
s'occupe de tout le monde mais on fait
avec les moyens du bord Valérie plante
merci beaucoup de nous avoir merci à la
prochaine au revoir